3 cette affaire de trump a été le
révélateur de ce qu'ont commencé à
soupçonner c'est-à-dire l'extraordinaire
défi que représentent les réseaux
sociaux pour la démocratie aujourd'hui
pour trump je sais pas il est possible
que ça dure en tout cas c'est
emblématique d'un problème réel posées
par les réseaux sociaux à la démocratie
dire qu'on n'avait pas prévu nos
institutions ne savais pas qu on
pourrait avoir une telle prise en main
de l'information il va falloir inventer
des formes de contrôle inventé aussi des
formes de légitimation démocratique à ce
qui aujourd'hui est totalement privée
totalement opaque est difficile à
déterminer c'est un vrai défi y compris
pour l'europe qui est en dehors du jeu
puisque ces grands acteurs ne sont même
pas chez elle est-ce que c'est dans la
garantie de certains droits à
l'expression moi c'est plutôt l'idée que
je défends on peut faire une forme de
modération mais a posteriori si vous la
faites à priori c'est là que vous allez
évidemment aseptisé les discours et
rendre les échanges impossible
peut-être censure ne va pas régler le
problème de la haine en ligne ou le
problème des de la radicalisation des
expressions c'est plutôt comparable à
une forme de couvercle qu'on va mettre
sur la cocotte-minute
c'est à dire que vous allez avoir un
déplacement de ses propositions un
déplacement aussi de ces vision
complotiste et des gens qui vont trouver
un moyen d'échangé et ils vont trouver
dans la censure la confirmation de leur
thèse on a voulu les faire taire c'est
pourquoi je ne pense pas malheureusement
que ces formes de censure soit des
solutions on peut tout à fait imaginer
qu'en france il commence à se développer
ce genre de d'asepsie un des échanges on
va pouvoir
petit à petit imposé ce qui est dit
cibler ce qui doit être caché on va
pouvoir bannir certaines personnes
certaines personnalités d'ailleurs ça
peut être déjà le cas sur twitter on n'a
pas tellement de recours à un moment où
un réseau pour une raison pour une autre
va décider que telle personne ne peut
plus s'exprimer
c'est tout à fait c'est tout à fait
clair que ce cette question elle est
posée aussi au débat français parce que
la façon dont les prochaines élections
en particulier les élections
présidentielles vont se faire passera
qu'on le veuille ou non aussi par un
questionnement sur la création de
l'opinion à travers les réseaux sociaux
on peut pas se contenter d'une mythe de
la neutralité malheureusement c'est plus
compliqué que ça